bonjour tu constance et de la police
avaient pas mis une annonce sur internet
vous de chambre à louer votre dossier
est retenu
merci marc choisissent la première fois
de ma vie que le destin d'un petit coup
de pouce mais déjà c'est une tartine de
merde c'est pas mes chaussons que vous
avez au pied il et les trois surtout
j'attends d'avoir un petit ami
non personne faut des règles pour vivre
en communauté montré que deux ça me
semble dire est énorme
bonjour vous êtes le fils n'ont voulu
m'appeler paul al thani et qu'elle était
à l'essai je suis pas suivi il fallait
gratter me dis la même chose toute mon
enfance mon fils est un abruti mot vers
le betis curé aujourd'hui la petite
hostie ça m'a fait comme un gâteaux
apéritifs et lui avec une idiote peuvent
le corps du christ n'est pas un gâteau
auditifs al jaber dans un grand bruit
vous pouvez pas me demander d'essayer de
briser un couple si vous acceptez je
vous fais trois mois gratuits
donnant donnant tout me trouver c'est
pas beau ce soir beaucoup trop vieux
pour vous sous les pins non si beaucoup
ne vous ai pas dit jamais deux chaises
bientôt tas de réentendre maman jouer tu
as intérêt à éviter ce genre de discours
abattoirs yens en quoi on entendra plus
jamais peur de nous et tu crèveras seul
quand le chien petit il était mignon
mais là c'est beaucoup d'écoles
chaque discothèque se dit plus discuté
avec maintenant on dit en boîte
je veux qu'ils aient tous le sera plus
je ne vais pas attendre davantage pour
faire ce que vous plaît on n'a qu'une
vie coffin